un grand respect à avoir pour ces gens
là est la moindre des choses c'est de
manifester notre soutien par notre
présence organisé pour la journée des
écrivains en prison du lundi 15 novembre
la 11e soirée des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés et empêcher se tenait à la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
trois écrivains se sont livrés à une
table ronde pour échanger autour de leur
histoire ces importantes pour au nom de
rencontre
les gens ici parce que je veux qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui avaient de
la france paris où il ne sait pas que
vraiment qu'est ce qui se passe dans
notre pays c'est important dit physique
et nous les personnes qui sont protégés
pour une france à proposer tous les
choses que si on passait chez nous dans
notre pays
nous sommes des personnes qui ont des
poudres en un parcours on bien avec des
histoires et on a des richesses à en
profiter à notre société intervenante de
la soirée l'artiste musical à marina
tour avaient déjà fui son pays natal la
colombie étant jeune
cette fois c'est le venezuela qu'elle a
quitté en raison des messages qu'elle
véhicule et lors de ses concerts entre
autres le féminisme la liberté des
jeunes si on dictature et c'est et c'est
dingue ira aussi donc et les personnes
qui est qu'ils sont en train de chercher
la liberté d'expression' n'ont pas la
place et cheissoux dans ces quatre là où
venezuela d'evra nef du régime à lui
était condamné dans son pays pour avoir
milité pour le droit d'étudier en langue
kurde j'étais un présent power 11 ans 3
mois et donc pendant mes années à
présent j'ai essayé d'écrire un kurde
aujourd'hui longue de kurdes pour
leekens est interdite mais par exemple
il ya une responsable s'il parlait coeur
pour je sais trés pour faire de
propaganda pour sl le troisième
intervenant anderson dea mitchell
journalistes haïtiens qui a subi
plusieurs tentatives d'assassinât dans
son pays pour son émission traitant de
sujets liés à la corruption une soirée
comme point final d'une semaine de
sensibilisation autour de la liberté
d'expression les trois réfugiés
politiques ont rencontré et discuté avec
plus de 400 élèves saint quentinois